Sim.
Quando você olha para a capacidade atual, acho que é
também uma pergunta muito importante: bem,
qual é o roteiro? Sabe, quanto
melhores esses sistemas ficam
e quão mais complexos
vão ser os circuits que conseguimos executar?
E para isso desenvolvemos uma métrica muito importante
chamada volume quântico.
Às vezes você pode ler ou ouvir na imprensa popular
o número de qubits, sabe,
como uma medida de progresso.
Vou ser direto:
o simples número de qubits na máquina não é uma
boa medida de progresso.
O progresso precisa ser medido pelo
nível de complexidade do circuit que você consegue executar.
Os qubits nessas boas máquinas não são perfeitos hoje
e eles têm erros introduzidos pelo acoplamento do
sistema com o mundo externo.
O próprio poder desses qubits,
o entrelaçamento e essas propriedades,
são o que os torna ao mesmo tempo poderosos
e delicados à interação
e conexão com o mundo externo.
Então você precisa reduzir a taxa de erros
enquanto aumenta o número de qubits.
É isso que está representado aqui.
O que você realmente quer fazer é se mover na diagonal,
e o volume quântico é uma medida que incorpora
ambas as métricas e algumas considerações adicionais importantes.